[Music]
this is sad news everything we have been
telling you for months we have been
reporting for months that the media has
ignored for over a year has been
confirmed this weekend I want you to pay
very close attention it gets somewhat
complicated but it's a sad chapter in
American history you have a trump
campaign associate his name is Carter
Paige he was spied on during the height
of the 2016 election by Barack Hussein
Obama's DOJ through the use of a FISA
warrant the hardest warrant to get and
tonight we know for sure totally
confirmed that the justification for
this warrant was a document you've heard
it before the unverified uncorroborated
phony dossier put together by a foreign
national with funneled money through a
law firm to an OP research group paid
for by Hillary Clinton and the DNC and
by the way this was all full of Russian
lies the whole bunch of it Russian lies
every single thing that they said about
Donald Trump was not true now we told
you about Perkins cuy the law firm we
told you about fusion GPS we told you
about the foreign national Christopher
steel they dug up dirt on Clinton's
opponent with Russian lies
let me repeat mr. Muller Russian lies to
the American people to affect the
outcome of a presidential election let
me put a more simply Obama's DOJ and FBI
were spying on the campaign of an
opposing party in a presidential
election year using op research that
Hillary Clinton paid for deep state
operatives tried to rig and steal a
presidential election this is what
happens in banana republics this is
Venezuela the type of propaganda would
rival Pravda in the former Soviet Union
this should never happen in the United
States of America period and the
mainstream corrupt media in this country
has been completely missing in action
make no mistake this phony dirty Russian
dossier wasn't just referenced in the
newly released documents on late
Saturday night in
Steele's dossier was in fact the FISA
application all four of them but still
look at your screen see these names
James call me Sally Yates Dana one day
and Andrew McCabe rod Rosenstein all
signed off on this warrant and all three
subsequent renewals they repeatedly lied
to FISA Court judges four separate times
rod Rosenstein lied
McCabe lied nothing new for him and
Yates & Co me and the rest of them all
lied and they all signed off on a
warrant application based on a document
that is so duplicitous even steel
himself in court proceedings in Great
Britain
conceded that the dossier was not
confirmed or verified he referred to it
as raw intelligence and he said the
chances of some of it even being true
were 50/50 and Christopher Steele was
ultimately fired as an FBI source for
lying and leaking and still in the FISA
warrants after his firing they claimed
to FISA judges that Steele was credible
he was fired for lying and leaking and
meanwhile James Comey admitted he knew
that dossier was unverified and
salacious and let's not forget fired
FBI director actually denied he told a
lie to our own Bret Baier that the
dossier was in fact playing a major role
in the FISA application the hardest
warrant to ever get they lied to the
judges repeatedly take a look I called
the dossier unverified salacious why did
you use that to the FISA Court to ask
for surveillance for Carter page not
only use it but you led with it a bulk
of that fire application deals with that
dossier why yeah that's not my
recollection Brett and I don't know that
the FISA application has been released
my recollection was it was part of a
broader mosaic of facts that were laid
before the FISA judge to obtain a FISA
warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the FISA application
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about page
and why there was probable cause to
believe he was an agent of a foreign
power and the dossier was part of that
but was not all of it or a critical part
of it what he said was a lie this line
was parented again and again by
Democrats the biggest liar in the
country Adam Schiff let's look at him
lying to you the information that was
used in Part II and the FISA application
came from a trusted source Christopher
Steele someone who was a respected
member of British intelligence and it
was part of a full package that was
presented to the FISA Court and it would
have been negligent frankly given what
the FBI knew about Carter page the
history that he had the fact had been a
target of Russian recruitment even prior
to this the fact that they went out and
interviewed him in March even before
Christopher Steele produced any part of
the so-called dossier that they were
acting in good faith know mr. Schiff you
knew and we all now know it was the bulk
of the application he's one of the
biggest liars in the country with 500 TV
appearances about that meanwhile
remember was the deputy AG rod
Rosenstein who was conflicted in so many
different ways he actually signed off on
the last final FISA renewal against
Carter page who had this to say
rod listen to your own words about the
sanctity of getting a FISA warrant what
you said back in May apply these
standards to yourself knowing what we
now know the way we operating the
Department of Justice if we can accuse
somebody of wrongdoing we have to have
admissible evidence and credible
witnesses we need to prepare to prove
our case in court and we have to fix our
signature to the charging document
that's something that not everybody
appreciates now there's a lot of talk
about FISA applications and many people
that I see talking about it seem not to
recognize what a FISA placate FISA
application is actually a warrant just
like a search warrant in order to get a
FISA search warrant you need an
affidavit signed by a career federal law
firm
an officer who swears that the
information in the affidavit is true and
correct to the best of his knowledge and
belief and that's the way we operate and
if that's wrong sometimes it is if you
find out there's anything incorrect in
there that person is going to face
consequences are you going to face
consequences Jeff Sessions where are you
tonight your country needs you to do
your job tonight and by the way is
Christopher steel rod is he credible to
you and to the best of Rods knowledge
the basis of the 2016 FISA warrant /
warrants against the Trump campaign
associate we now know the following it
was unverified it was uncorroborated as
rod Rosenstein said it must be it was
untrue it was a document full of Russia
lies and they all signed off on it and
by the way in fact everyone who signed
off on this misled FISA Court just
judges and propagated lies in order to
knowingly spy on a campaign and rigged a
presidential election in their favor and
the media took this bait they were fed
by Christopher Steele at the behest of
fusion GPS and they sent it out to the
media it is the biggest single scandal
in American history and your media is
deaf blind and dumb and overpaid and
lazy which brings us to Carter page now
tonight besides and despite extensive
surveillance from the federal government
why is it page hasn't been charged with
a crime has anyone asked that question
despite Obama's DOJ alleging he might be
a Russian agent what they told the FISA
courts why is Carter page a free man
tonight in fact according to page and I
interviewed him for an hour on radio
today he actually was debriefed by the
CIA and the FBI after many of his visits
to Russia cooperating with them helping
his own government he said here's what
he said on my radio show it's funny not
only did they lie it's they have two
main themes which are totally
contradictory they call me a quote
unquote foreign agent but then at the
same time they say I'm a target of
recruit
right so which one is it I mean there's
so many inconsistencies and it's it's
just completely beyond comprehension our
own gregg jarrett who's reporting has
been flawless in all of this will join
us in a minute
probably summed up this document best
and according to his legal analysis here
are the main takeaways from the FISA
warrant first the warrant application
was the dossier like we've been saying
front and center the bulk of information
that means new Ness was right the
Grassley Graham memo was right the
Democrats lied the FISA Court was
purposefully misled on a lot of fronts
and not explicitly told the nature of
this unverified dossier with Russian
lies there would have been no warrant
without the dossier remember even Andrew
McCabe said that James Comey lied about
the dossiers role in this warrant the
FISA Court never knew Hillary bought and
paid for this they purposely withheld
that kind of important piece of
information and the FBI were lied on
news accounts and lie to judges
including what's called circular
reporting from Yahoo News they used the
dossier as the basis for one of their
reports Steele lied but was still quote
credible by the FBI does that make sense
Paige has never been indicted the FBI
never actually interviewed Paige
although he said he was back at March to
me the dossier was unverified and yet it
was used to obtain warrants
how dare rod Rosenstein and everybody
else sign off on that they are now
violating shredding our Constitution
violating our Fourth Amendment rights
and why is it all redacted let's give it
to the American people trey Gowdy even
said he's seen no collusion from this
document up and still tonight we have
even more questions than even earlier
this FISA application is heavily
redacted the American people deserve to
see it I am calling for all of this
warrant to be unredacted the president
can do this and according to my sources
if the final FISA warrant is released
rod Rosenstein is finished as his role
in his role as deputy AG but now because
of the blatant abuse
of power that took place at the highest
levels of your government the Trump
administration rightly tonight is taking
important steps and calling for certain
Obama era officials to be stripped of
their security clearances this should
have happened a long time ago knowing
what we now know take a look
not only is the president looking to
take away
Brennan's security clearance he's also
looking into the clearances of combing
clapper Hayden rice and McCabe the
president is exploring the mechanisms to
remove security clearance because
they've politicized and in some cases
monetize their public service and
security clearances making baseless
accusations of improper contact with
Russia or being influenced by Russia
against the president is extremely
inappropriate and the fact that people
with security clearances are making
these baseless charges provides
inappropriate legitimacy to accusations
with zero evidence
well said Sara Sanders right on the
money thank God they all abused their
power the power that we give them none
of them should have security clearances
it's all true they fixed the
investigation to help their favorite
candidate Hillary Clinton the worst
obstruction of justice case I've ever
seen in my life and in the case of
Hillary mislead the American people
literally she violated the Espionage Act
mishandled classified top-secret special
access programming information and
destroyed such two separate felonies
then rigged an investigation clearly
into Donald Trump their security
clearances and are now obviously a clear
and present danger to this country and
meanwhile the press is spinning in
circles but let us be clear tonight all
these people involved in the biggest
political scandal of our lifetime robert
muller this is your collusion story
robert muller maybe you want to get your
pitbull andrew Weissman on this Hillary
Clinton the DNC and the paid for Russian
Lies to rig an election and lie to the
American people all done at the highest
levels of our government
you literally using a
or process a lying to judges and the
bulk of the information judges are fed
so that they can spy on an opposition
party candidate associate is full of
Russian lies so maybe you'll have a
little more time on your hands and go
after if I may these lies that were
bought and paid for by Hillary to Russia
all designed to propagandize the
American people let me put it another
way
lie to the American people mr. Muller do
your job tonight
if you care about truth if you care
about justice if you care about the
system of justice in this country being
abused at this high level if you care
that somebody actually paid for Russian
lies to miss inform the American people
and that information was spread by some
of the highest levels of our government
how do you justify Russian lies being
used to get a warrant on an American
citizen it was never verified it was
never corroborated it was never even
looked at it was just propagated and
these judges when are we gonna hear from
them I never met a judge in my life that
likes to be lied to where I grew up
where my mom's a prison guard and my dad
had worked in family court probation yes
sir no sir
yes ma'am no man yes your honor no Your
Honor may it please the court may it
please the court that these judges now
be told that they've been lied to to
this extent by our own top officials in
our government to steal an election